where does genius come from pablo
picasso's journey to genius began with a
puff of his uncle salvador cigar
so claims the man himself it's possible
this puff ignited what some historians
call the rage to master a voracious
dedication to push the boundaries of
one's craft this obsessive personality
led Picasso down a lifelong path of
bucking established traditions I am not
in favor of following any determined
school because that only brings about
similarity among adherents when Picasso
moved to Paris at the age of 22 he fell
in with like-minded Bohemians like
Richard Stein and Henri Matisse from
this creative cauldron emerged perhaps
Picasso's most famous contribution to
art history a radical style called
cubism with displaced noses and mouths
and characteristic irregular forms
cubism nicely encapsulated Picasso's
aesthetic or view a picture used to be a
sum of editions with me a picture is a
sum of destructions so it was throughout
his career
Picasso constantly reinvented his style
at a rapid pace
he created thousands of innovative
sculptures drawings matchings
ceramics and paintings neuroscientists
have discovered that imagery like
Picasso's invites viewers into the
creative process with the artists fleas
relish taking incomplete clues in the
missing details
Picasso had an instinct for this dynamic
long before science corroborated it the
picture leaves only to the man who is
looking at it
you
[Music]